new app could help parents interpret why
their baby's upset based on how they cry
the free app chatter baby was released
last month it analyzes the acoustic
features of a baby's cry to help parents
understand whether their child might be
hungry
let's see or in pain or a big ol poopy
diaper while critics say caregivers
should not rely too much on their
smartphone others say this actually
could be a helpful tool for new and
weary parents Jamie yuccas spoke with
one family that's actually tried it like
many new parents fátima Bell is often
trying to figure out why her five month
old son Jonathan jr. is crying
it's scary you're responsible for
someone's life she says the chatter baby
app helps her and her husband Jonathan
identify what's bothering their son more
quickly they record his cries for five
seconds and the app tells them the
likelihood that he's fussy hungry or in
pain for me it just goes down a mental
checklist of you know what do I need to
do to you this app is bored just a gut
check yeah it was to confirm what I was
feeling basically and knowing that like
I'm doing the right things and the
patterns that I'm doing it the app was
developed by UCLA statistician Arianna
Anderson a mother of four she originally
designed the technology to help deaf
parents like the wetters better
understand why their baby was upset but
soon realized it could be a helpful tool
for all new parents when I became a
parent I had just finished my PhD and I
thought I was very very smart and then I
had a baby and I felt like an idiot
because I couldn't understand what my
baby needed it was very very stressful
and overwhelming for me to build a
database Anderson and her team uploaded
2000 audio samples of infant cries she
used cries recorded during ear piercings
and vaccinations to distinguish pain
cries sad
yeah and to create a baseline for the
other two categories a panel of moms had
a unanimously agree on whether the cry
was either hungry or fussy for taking a
five-second audio sample we look at over
6,000 different acoustic features and we
try to see which features associated
with each state using artificial
intelligence Anderson's team continues
to collect data and hopes to make the
app more accurate by asking parents to
get more specific about what certain
sounds mean we have things like ear
infection we have colic we have tired we
have every possible reason Under the Sun
because we want to be able to increase
the number of words in our vocabulary
later on I think that all of the apps
and technology that new parents are
using now can be helpful but need to be
taken with a grain of salt pediatrician
Eric ball points out evaluating cries
can never be an exact science I do worry
that some parents will get bogged down
in big data and turn their parenting
into basically a spreadsheet which I
think will take away from the love and
caring and support that parents are
supposed to be providing for their
children we're trying to make it in a
way that parents have to interpret the
results not that we give them a
yes-or-no answer do you worry that you
might get too dependent on the phone to
tell you what's going on with him and
we're only getting better by way of
technology but I wouldn't rely on a 100%
but I would utilize it the bells say
it's a win-win they believe they're not
only helping their baby now but
potentially others in the future you
want to try to help out as much as you
can so if I can do something or if my
little guy can do something that helps
the next guy out then why wouldn't you
huh for CBS this morning I'm Jamie
yuccas that was my favorite part dad
looking with my little guy and he's
clearly engaged with the baby because
really there's only so many options your
baby's crying so that the the picture of
her holding the app over trying to
decide what to do through me a little
bit but adding the death helping depth
returns yeah took it in another
direction for me